it's a special friday edition of
p-f-t-o-t we waited to do this one
because we thought there was a chance
the nfl would act quickly and decisively
with brown's defensive end miles garrett
and that is precisely what the league
did the proverbial friday afternoon bad
news dump coming before friday afternoon
technically even began just before 12
o'clock eastern the nfl announces a
variety of punishments we're going to
begin with the main culprit here miles
garrett who removed the helmet of
steelers quarterback mason rudolph and
then struck rudolph in the head with his
own helmet garrett has been suspended
indefinitely but he definitely will miss
the rest of the regular season plus any
playoff games for which the browns may
qualify so up to 10 games and don't
laugh in theory the browns could still
make it to the super bowl but up to 10
games in 2019 then he'll have to meet
with the commissioner regarding a
potential reinstatement for 2020. it's
possible he misses no further games it's
possible he misses four games or more to
start the 2020 regular season and it is
possible that
whether or not the browns make the
playoffs the games he would miss in 2019
maybe if he misses a playoff game or two
in 2019
that is one or two fewer games he would
miss in 2020 but either way
garrett's punishment preliminarily has
been set at a minimum of six games and
he will have the ability to appeal that
decision more on that in a second though
for now the cost to miles garrett
1.139 million in salary that he will
lose from missing the final six games of
the 2019 regular season plus if the
browns are inclined to do so they could
pursue forfeiture of signing bonus money
applicable to the six games he'll miss
that works out
to
1.782 million dollars again if the
browns choose to pursue that avenue
sometimes teams do sometimes they don't
it works out to more than 2.9 million in
potential expenses for miles garrett
just based upon a six-game regular
season suspension the league has also
said he'll be fined an amount over and
above whatever he would lose by way of
salary so an expensive swinging of the
helmet and a justifiable outcome
something like this had never happened
before in the nfl and you think about
all of the dirty moments we've seen all
of the unfortunate incidents that went
beyond the boundaries of a given play to
remove someone's helmet and actually
strike them in the head with it is a
criminal act and i don't believe that
miles garrett will be prosecuted but he
could be and if this had happened in
pittsburgh instead of cleveland maybe he
would be because let's remember
prosecutors are publicly elected
officials and
prosecutors have a wide degree of
discretion when it comes to who they
will charge and who they won't charge
but in a case like this the evidence of
an assault is open and shut and even
though miles garrett probably doesn't
have to worry about that he does have to
worry about the league and what the
league has done so far has put him on
the sidelines for the rest of the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports